I’m a turn ’em loose so we can
play with them a little while.
[kisses] Hey, puppies!
You know,
they’re progressing good.
They learning.
Each time you take ’em out,
they get a little better
and a little better.
The mama had
a little bitty short tail,
and the daddy had
a regular sized tail,
big old beagle tail,
and they all
took after the mama.
[kisses]
[whistles]
Half rabbit dog
and half squirrel dog.
[kisses]
Come on, puppy!
I love raising puppies.
I’ve raised puppies all my life
and trained them.
Should have been working ’em
a little more
than I been working them.
I usually start ’em when they’re
a little smaller than this.
These are kind of big.
I shoulda
had ’em started already.
But they gonna catch on.
They catch on quick.
Rabbit season’s
just around the corner.
When they gonna be
about six months old,
I better take ’em in the woods
and go rabbit hunting.
[whistles]
Can you tell Pa what that is?
- It looks like,
um, coon tracks.
- No. That’s rabbit tracks.
Coons got long fingers.
See, that’s a rabbit track,
little short and pointy.
Remember, they always
comes to a point,
that little rabbit,
and it’s about the size
of the end of your finger.
Look at ’em.
They got that nose down.
They’re smellin’.
[puppies bark]
- A rabbit!
- Come here, Rascal!
Come here, Ras!
[laughs]
Run, little rabbit, run.
There’s one
that can’t even come close
to keeping up with the rabbit.
That rabbit
got a good hidin’ place.
He let the puppies get close.
He plays with the puppies.
He lets ’em get close,
and then he takes off
into the trees.
- There’s a hole kind of...
See that hole over there
in that tree.
Something similar to that,
but it’s perfect for a rabbit.
And he goes straight into that
hole in the tree every time.
Come here, puppy!
[kisses]
They’re still lookin’ for him.
Good job, little puppy!
Good job!
- Yeah, they fast
for three months old.
Not as fast as you,
though, bubba.
You was faster
than the puppies, huh?